Iran's attorney general Muhammad Jafar
Montessori announced in the city of Gom
late Saturday evening that the morality
police is no longer operational
according to the Judiciary who says that
they are not involved in this unit and
that from where the morality police were
formed they have been stopped operating
now it's not clear what the Attorney
General meant when it comes to what
happens next he did say however that the
issue of mandatory hijab is still to be
taken very seriously and that cultural
measure should be taken prior to any
other measures the Attorney General
who's been in position since 2016 also
state that the issue of mandatory hijab
is still very much part of the country's
laws what it does mean now is for the
time being this unit that was formed in
2006 to enforce the rules in Iran when
it comes to women being covered in
public is now no longer operating in
public what comes next is unclear what
will happen to those officers that were
part of this unit and also the main
question now is who will be in charge of
enforcing their laws and rules of
mandatory hijab in Iran many analysts
have spoken to say that this
announcement comes at a time that you've
seen on a precedented level of protests
that began with the death of Masa and
Mimi while in police
it is likely that this is an attempt by
officials to try and calm the situation
many of the demonstrators we've spoken
to over the past few weeks say that the
issue of mandatory hijab may have been
the starting point for their
demonstrations on the streets across the
country but now it's become much larger
it demands that they're making of the
government